[موسيقى]
كما تعلم هذا البرنامج اقر منذ نهايه
العام الماضي وابتدا العمل فيه فريق العمل
فريق صندوق النقد الدولي يتعاون مع
السلطات المصريه لجهه
تطبيق السياسات وايضا الاصلاحات الضروريه
لتنفيذ المراجعه الاولى والمراجعه الثانيه
هذه الاجراءات وهذه الاصلاحات ضروريه
لاعاده انعاش الاقتصاد المصري ليتمكن من
مواجهه تحديات التضخم من جهه وايضا تامين
فرص العمل هي اجراءات على اربع محاور
المحور الاول اعاده تنشيط دور القطاع
الخاص اعاده نظر بالانفاق الحكومي ودور
المؤسسات العامه سياسه مرونه سعر
الجنيه المصري لحمايه الاقتصاد المصري من
الصدمات الخارجيه وسياسه مليه تعتمد على
رفع القدره الميليه للحكومه و تحول سياسات
الانفاق الى تكون اكثر
[موسيقى]
استهدافا بما لاشك في انه الامور والازمات
المناخيه والطبيعيه الى انعكاسات كبيره
على الاقتصاد
تاثر بالدرجه الاولى من خلال القدره
الانتاجيه تقلصها فيبعض الاحيان بمستويات
كبيره ال ايضا انعكاس على ميزانيه العامه
والانفاق حيث من الضروري اعاده الاعمار
دعم الذين تاثروا بهذه الكوارس الطبيعيه
وايضا لها تاثير على القدره على تنشيط
الاقتصاد لانه بتشكل بتشكل تاثيرات على
الحركه الاقتصاديه مما لا شك في يتغير او
منسوب التاثير بحسب قدره الاقتصاديه وقدره
النهوض عند البلد انما هذا يشير خاصه
بالدول اللي هي اكثر ضعفا وهشاشه لاهميه
معالجه المشكله المناخيه وهو احدى
اهم التحديات للسنوات المقبله والصندوق
يعمل جاهدا لمساعده دول المنطقه حول هذا
الامر كما تعلم خلال الاسابيع الماضيه اقر
قرد جديد للمغرب للمساعده بعمليه مواجهه
التحديات المناخيه وايضا الق على التحو
واتخاذ الاجراءات اللي بتحد من انتشار
الاحداث المناخيه وتاثيرها السلبي على
الاقتصاد وتاثير السلبي على حياه
المواطنين بالحقيقه مثل ما تفضلت وقلت
يتباطا الاقتصاد في المنطقه بالتوازي مع
تباطؤ الاقتصاد العالمي من المتوقع انه
نسبه النمو هذا العام ان تكون بحوالي
2% ياتي هذا الامر
بعده سبب عده امور
اهمها التقليص التدريجي من خلال تمديد
اتفاقيه اوبك بلس يلي كان له الوقع على
مستوى النمو بالناتج المحلي النفطي لهذا
السبب اذا نظرنا مثلا الى الدول المصدره
للنفط نرى انه ما يقود النمو حاليا هذا
العام هو نمو القطاع غير النفطي هناك ايضا
تطورات اخرى اثرت على مستويات النمو لهذا
العام السياسات المتش شدده للجم مستويات
التضخم والتاقلم مع الاجراءات التي تتم
حاليا عالميا لي كمان كان لها انعكاس على
النمو وخاصه بالدول المستورده للنفط ويبقى
ان هناك كمان حالات خاصه لبعض البلدان
اللي تاثرت هذا العام باحداث كما مثلا
السودان اللي تاثر
بالصراع الداخلي وايضا بلدان تاثرت بامور
الها علاقه بالتغير المناخي كما شاهدنا
مؤخرا في
[موسيقى]
ليبيا موضوع التضخم هو تحدي كبير لكثير
دول بالعالم ودول المنطقه ومن المفيد
الاشاره لاله انه التضخم بدا يتراجع
بالعام 2023 وخاصه ايضا بالعام
2024 يبقى بعض البلدان اللي هي عندها
حالات خاصه حيث مستوى التضخم سيبقى مرتفع
اهميه تراجع مستوى التضخم انه له انعكاس
سلبي على الاستقرار الاقتصادي وايضا يؤدي
الى تحسن الاوضاع الاجتماعيه نظرا لان
الارتفاع الكبير بالاسعار يتاتى من ارتفاع
اسعار المواد الغذائيه ياتي ذلك بسبب
السياسات التي اعتمدت السياسات
النقديه المحافظه يلي ساهمت بتخفيض تدريجي
ل مستويات الاسعار يضاف اليها انه بعض
البلدان تعتمد على على سياسات الدعم يلي
خفضت اذا بدي اقول التحول ارتفاع الاسعار
عالميا لبعض الخدمات او بعض السلع الى
الاسعار الداخليه يبقى انه من الضروري
اليوم المواكبه بين امرين المحافظه على
الاستقرار من خلال الابقاء على سياسات
نقديه وسياسات ماليه محافظه بذات الوقت
العمل من خلال اصلاحات هيكليه على تحسين
مستويات النمو لمعالجه المشاكل يلي هي
مشاكل مزمنه مثل فرص العمل وغيرها كمان
هون دول الخليج مستويات النمو فيها كانت
مرتفعه بالعام الماضي ومستويات التضخم
منخفضه وما زالت منخفضه بالمقارنه بعد بعض
البلدان ارتفعت فيها مستويات التضخم لتفوق
ال 15 او ال 20% العام
الماضي شكرا على سؤالك بالطبع هذا سؤال عم
ينسال بس انما هيدا مش المناسبه ومثل ما
بتعرف موضوعنا اليوم
هو اطلاق التقرير حول افاق الاقتصاديه
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط من ضمن فعاليات
الاجتماعات السنويه اللي عم تتم حاليا
بالمغرب
بمراكش